when you look in the field that i really
love is artificial intelligence and
there's not many projects there's not
many
little flames of hope that have been
carried out for many years for decades
and psych represents one of them
and uh
i mean that in itself is just a really
inspiring thing
so i'm i'm deeply grateful that you
would be carrying that flame for so many
years and i think that's an inspiration
to young people
that said you said life is finite and we
talked about mortality is a feature of
agi
do you think about your own mortality
are you afraid of death
um
sure i'd be crazy if i weren't and
as i get older i'm now
over 70. so as i get older
it's more on my mind especially as
acquaintances and friends and especially
mentors
one by one are dying so i can't avoid
thinking about mortality and i think
that
the the good news from the point of you
and the rest of the world is that that
adds impetus to uh my need to succeed in
a small number of years in the future
because i have a deadline
exactly i'm not going to have another 37
years to continue working on this so we
really do want psych to make an impact
in the world
commercially
physically metaphysically
in the next small number of years two
three five years not two three five
decades anymore and so this is really
driving me toward
uh this this sort of commercialization
and increasing increasingly widespread
application
of psych whereas before um i felt that i
could just sort of sit back roll my eyes
wait till the world caught up and now i
don't feel that way anyway anymore i
feel like i need to put in some effort
to
make the world aware of what we have and
what it can do
and the good news from your point of
view is that that's that's why i'm
sitting here and you're gonna be more
productive
[Laughter]
uh and i love it and if i can help in
any way i would love to from uh from you
know from a programmer perspective
i love
especially these days just contributing
in small and big ways so if there's any
open sourcing from the mit side and the
research i would love to help
but
you know bigger than psych like i said
it's that little flame that you're
carrying of artificial intelligence the
big dream
is there
what do you hope your legacy is
that's a good question
that people think of me as
one of the
pioneers or inventors
of
the ai that is ubiquitous and that they
take for granted um and so on much much
the way that
today we look back on the the pioneers
of electricity or the pioneers of
similar types of technologies and so on
as
you know it's hard to imagine what life
would be like if these people hadn't
done what they
um what they did so that that's one
thing
that i'd like to be remembered as
another is that so the creator one of
the origin originators of this
gigantic knowledge
store and acquisition system that is
likely to be at the center
of whatever this future ai thing will
look like exactly and i'd also like to
be remembered as someone who
wasn't afraid to
spend
several decades
on a project in a time when
all when almost all of the
other forces
institutional forces and commercial
forces
are incenting people to go for
short-term rewards and a lot of people
gave up a lot of people that
dreamt the same dream as you
gave up yes and you didn't yes
i mean uh doug it's it's truly an honor
this was a long time coming i i
a lot of people bring up your work
uh specifically and more broadly
philosophically of this is the dream of
artificial intelligence this is likely a
part of the future we're so sort of
focused on machine learning applications
all that kind of stuff today but it
seems like the ideas that psych carries
forward
uh is something that would be at the
center
of this problem they're all trying to
solve which is the the problem of
intelligence
emotional and
and uh otherwise so thank you so much
it's such a huge honor that you would
talk to me and spend your valuable time
with me today thanks for talking thanks
lex it's been great
you